ma il beau geste ragazzi e benvenute
questo nuovissimo video siamo ritornati
suddetto tali a roma vabbè è quello
delle battaglie e quello delle battaglie
inalmente ho sbloccato i giganti per
poter giocare online perché vediamo che
si potevano sgorgare adesso li ho
sbloccato però prima di giocarla un
perché cerceri o può effettivamente
adesso non si vedono sporcato che non
sono online non li posso usare però
volevo provare a fare la simulazione che
questa modalità praticamente che è la
modalità campagna però sul ponte sospeso
guerra la cosa che avete visto
impossibile se riesco a vincere questa
allora posso fare quello che voglio
sostanzialmente però partiamo col mammut
secondo me qua ma molto fan disastro
però è uno era spettato se posso mettere
due ne posso mettere 22 mammut i due
marchi delle ossa ecco così peron
esagerazione prova vediamole
mi sa che i mammut sono un pelo che però
è caduto cacchio ho perso perché il
clima multa è caduto giù la mettiamo
solo un mammut perché l'altro cade gli
altri tira lancerà gatto di dire arance
sono me ci siamo non è anche fin troppo
però proviamo cile gol allora un po uno
è caduto e va bene ok quelli ok ma che
sono forti ai cavalieri comunque avrò
una put call call a mood è morto il
problema del mammut ragazze che blocca
la strada tutti quanti non si capisce
una sega
seguono i problemi se il mammut non cade
cadiamo noi tutti ragazzi non a ok sta
sprofondando nel ponte non chiedetemi
come sia possibile prova bene e che
lancia i palloncini ma scusa ragazzi ma
è bravino reagite che cacchio ponte
lamberti vai e i premi se ne sono andati
a farsi [ __ ]
però c'è un sacco di gente che spara
vedo bravo il mama
bravo è morto e quali sono morti pure
ora è giusto tutto nei maiali perfetto i
maghi delle ossa non sono così forti
ricordiamo il no in realtà volevo vedere
se c'è il secondo me qua al minotauro fa
casino perché il minotauro ti permette
di caricare tutti quanti e potrebbe aver
senso contro messico a ok quindi un
minotauro e poi gente che aspetta da
lontano e gaggio integrata cantano per
forza li metto sul ponte vediamo che
succede
van persie si buttano giovane allora si
prendono le mazzate ottimo mio toro non
è male è perché un pò di gente la butta
giù vedo ok ha resistito di non aver
meglio del mammut perfetto
sono morti tutti chicca che rimane però
è arrivato un arciere a posto ce
l'abbiamo fatta
evita l'aveva presa nel deretano ragazze
difficilissimo questo è difficile un
miliardo di bardi che servono soltanto
per dar fastidio poi un miliardo di
arcieri era una catapulta la catapulta
non potrebbe trovare un essere male
perché il pieno di gente quindi
catapulta real così raga c'è un po di
gel e catapulta e dovrebbero far casino
più che altrove c'è gente c'è più avanti
ma questa si incastrano tra di loro lega
non vale però sono attivi ai mini
davanti non attaccano il problema allora
fermi c'è qualcosa che non c'è la
battaglia imposti da battaglia non si
può fare ma come ok ragazzi faccio
partire la catapulta dai fondi in modo
tale che gli altri abbiano tempo di fare
le cose
ho preso dei moschettieri io ho preso un
po di roba vediamo che succede
ok moschettieri perfetto catapulta
dovete dovete prendere ecco niente non è
così distanza è impossibile se la taglia
non si può fare non so perché legata
pure i ragazzi che catapulterà vi sono
ammazzato i miei stessi le catapulte
devono fare danno fate danno o questo le
dà un ora e mezza che tentò di fare sta
cosa
ok ok adesso
praga è il livello più difficile di sto
cacchio di gioco proviamo così raga
colman mood molto più dietro che per
caricare ci mette due ore non lo so non
saprei che fare questo schermisce un po
di gente aspetta che si radunino tutti e
dopo di che il mammut e li carica
[Musica]
perfetto sarebbe utile che il mammut
meritasse gli altri dietro prima però
vabbè se carichi forse ce la fai però
devi caricare adesso zio devi caricare
adesso carica e ci ha messo troppo tempo
a caricare a sesto dietro sesto dietro
il re non mi prendono attenzione questa
è buona
ok peccato che non è andato dopo
superato io però non fa niente vai vai
vai e vai dei vari e variegati mi
colpiscono non so come cazzo perché c'è
ray davanti non dovrebbero farlo proprio
che adesso spara un colpo a caso ok ce
lo fa ci metto sempre un ora a prendere
sta cosa comunque ok
ma a volte spara storto stappa rosso
posso cambiarla
metto togli la turista marmetto dov'è
questo il cannoniere il canone è normale
perché questo fa cagare orribile il
cannoniere già più saggia almeno spara
dove dove dovere sparare a minchia la
catapulta non ha proprio senso almeno il
cannoniere spara dritto spara un po sui
miei è però va bene ok
peccato che non ho sparato doveva è
andato il colpo menzione ci sono solo
quelli dietro ho preso il migliore ok
accesso rimasto solo io non è male
questo nei vasi 2 not reagan chio uno
per ok madonna raga ce l'avevo fatta per
uno per uno solo che questo forse riesco
a schivarlo java è sparato in tempo
mamma mia il livello più difficile di
questo gioco finito ci ho messo mezz'ora
mezz'ora ci ho messo mezz'ora a fare
stato ve lo giuro mezz'ora è stato
difficilissimo ragazzi pazzesco non sono
anche spiegarvi come ce l'ho fatta
madonna rega è stata la cosa più brutta
è difficile della storia mezz'ora ci ho
messo però mammamia meno male a famiglia
secondo dopo è difficile quanto volo
prima giusto per curiosità 3 o così
ragazzi ho preso sorgente forte
non vedo né a non riesco neanche a
seguire tutti gli scontri sono anche
capello che succede
non vedo succedono robe però secondo me
non vinco buono o forse sì dai
ho vinto un tentativo fatto l'altro non
fatti 2000 pazzesco nova basta sta gente
basta non ne voglio non ne voglio li
voglio più vedere non li voglio più
vedere maronna che casino è ancora vivo
reo stanno menando perfetto solo
cannonieri che succede là dietro ho
ammazzato roma non solo sta succedendo
là dietro
e non è finita ha scelto uno è morto
yes signori spero che questo migliori
tabs vi sia piaciuto cosa in sé vivere
la moto mi piace anche questo cercando
per l'occasione sono stati gli schietti
e noi ragazzi come sempre ci vediamo a
un prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]
no